[Música]
bienvenidos a directo con 26 el nuevo
espacio de france 24 para entender a
profundidad qué está pasando en la
cumbre climática de glasgow hoy mañana
son los días clave en los que los
mandatarios de más de 120 países
discuten que ahoran concretamente para
frenar el calentamiento global y ya se
conocieron los primeros anuncios
conectamos a esta hora con nuestra
enviada especial marina colorada ola
marina y cuéntenos que líderes hablaron
y especialmente qué significan estas
nuevas promesas ambientales
bueno ha sido un día lleno de
expectativa y de discursos de líderes
bastante con bastante poder en la mesa
de decisión empezó la sesión de líderes
la empezó pedro sánchez del presidente
del gobierno español ya que fue el
anfitrión de la cob 25 en 2019 él habló
de aumentar en un 50 por ciento la
financiación actual que tienen para
ayudar a los países menos desarrollados
unos minutos después habló el presidente
de eeuu joe biden que dijo que su país
va a reducir en una gigatonelada las
emisiones de efecto invernadero también
estuvo el presidente de francia emmanuel
macrón quien habló de los desafíos de
implementar el acuerdo verde de la unión
europea y también mostró o dijo que
había que mostrar más solidaridad con
los países menos desarrollados el
presidente de la república popular de
china xi jinping
no puso no está aquí en la cumbre
presente para empezar eso es un buen
dato también pero china el país como tal
no propuso nuevos compromisos de
neutralidad de carbono con más allá de
los que ya propuso hace unos meses con
neutralidad a 2060 india uno de los
países más contaminantes también el
primer ministro narendra modi anunció
que
habrá que llegaran a la neutralidad de
carbono en el año 2000 70 20 años
después de lo que es la meta global en
cuanto a latinoamérica habló de luís
arce el presidente de bolivia y dijo que
los líderes no están mostrando ninguna
responsabilidad con la madre tierra ya y
bolsonaro presidente de brasil no estuvo
presente en la cumbre pero mandó un
vídeo un mensaje por vídeo y anunció que
el su país aumentará del 43 por ciento
al 50 por ciento las sus metas de
reducción de emisiones de carbono y el
propósito de estos anuncios de brasil
usted está con un activista ambiental de
este país sudamericano cuéntenos que
tiene él por decirnos
sí pues me acompaña jaime silvestre él
es activista ambiental como bien lo dijo
y él le queríamos preguntar qué piensas
tú acerca de los anuncios que hizo el
presidente bolsonaro hoy acerca de la
aume del aumento de la reducción de
emisiones hola a todos el plan
presentado por el gobierno es una falsa
cuestionario no nos preocupa como clima
del planeta desde este que posicionar o
asumido el gobierno ha
desmantelado las políticas públicas de
protecciones ambientales de protecciones
de establos de indignas indígenas en
relación precisamente hablando de los
pueblos indígenas cuál es el rol que
juega esta comunidad de estos pueblos en
el mundo entero no solo en brasil en
protección del medio ambiente y de la
naturaleza
las comunidades indígenas son
responsables por la protección de la
biodiversidad por tanto la comunidad
indígena necesita de protección del
estado pues por ejemplo la inversión
bolsonaro no tienes
dedicado investimentos para la
protección de los
pueblos indígenas esto es muy triste si
no hacemos un gobierno genocida
la comunidad internacional tiene equipo
está presión
englaro y usted forma parte de dos
organizaciones ambientales de jóvenes
viernes por el futuro y huelga por el
clima en brasil cuál es el papel que
ustedes hacen qué es lo que quieren
conseguir
nosotros como jóvenes tenemos tenemos un
deber cívico del lugar del planeta
puedan hacer la biodiversidad la
protección de las tierras de las
comunidades indígenas por tanto nosotros
estamos acá para presionar los gobiernos
de tomar decisiones ciertas por la
protesta por la protección del planeta
pero porque estamos hablando de nuestras
vidas es muy importante esto existe
estamos activos muchísimas gracias jaime
silvestre por el tiempo en directo con
26 ya ustedes recuerden que seguimos con
todo este segmento todos los días de la
cob 26 de lunes a sábado maría clara
gracias marina por este reporte y
gracias a nuestro invitado jaime
silvestre y como lo decía marina
nosotros tendremos este espacio de lunes
a sábado todos los días a la hora y
cuarto de la tarde en hora bogotá quito
lima sigan 224 y con directo con 26
[Música]